solitude's an interesting idea it all
has to do with what you're processing
Solitude is freedom from input from
other Minds so if you're processing
something that was generated from
another mind you're not in a state of
solitude our brain takes very seriously
the idea that okay this input we're
getting right now came from another
human being so it has nothing to do with
physical isolation it's crucial for
humans to have Solitude on a regular
basis it takes a lot of power for our
brain to okay all hands on deck there's
another human mind that we're processing
right now so if you're always doing that
the brain doesn't get down Cycles so
you're going to get anxiety other types
of issues it's also crucial for
self-development and insight generation
if our brain is in processing mode it
can't actually be making sense in any
sort of significant degree of the
information that is processing so to get
solids in your life is as easy as just
some of the places where you used to
have it even when you're really busy you
get it back by just not using your phone
on my commute today I'm not going to put
on the podcast for the first 20 minutes
or when I'm walking a dog I'm not
putting in the earbuds so it's stuff
that you're already doing just do some
of those things without the slot machine
and the constant access to Solitude
busting information